titles first of all welcome to the
studio welcome back to st louis how does
it feel to be playing over the board
chess here in st louis
well it was feeling great at the start
but then disaster strikes you know
sometimes in chess and uh in that game
against hungaski yeah yeah we have to
ask
what happened what happened well i
forgot that the rook moved from f2 like
uh after rook g2 i thought i had rook h2
and it's just uh latinate yeah but then
the king
escapes to f2 and i'm just lost so i
i saw the evaluation drop from plus six
to minus three so i basically dropped
the queen in one move
yeah pretty much the equivalent yeah
and they called me a grandmaster so it
was
pretty shameful to be honest but um
and then yeah i kind of checked out for
the for the next
three rounds honestly but today chris
was under a lot of pressure i think you
know with the black pieces playing for
first how did you approach today's round
you knew that that is his situation what
was your situation i'm not playing for
anything i'm just making moves you know
he wants to beat me i'm just gonna
tuckle down and let him beat me if you
you know if you can do it um but
yeah i think the pressure kind of got to
him to be honest let's look at the game
uh which ones do you think were the
critical moments of this one
i think he uh he rushed with uh
with f4 um
i think this position yeah was very nice
for black right like if you look uh
right here right
perfectly developed
um but then he tried these forcing moves
with uh f4 and uh
i kind of managed to break in the center
and by the way i think uh we do have a
result in that critical match up it
seems like abimanu has won his game
against christopher you and has won
group b of the spring chess classic
congratulations to the world's youngest
grand master
there you go abimanu mishra look at look
at the production value it's just
through the roof today winner of uh
group b certainly congratulations to him
uh yeah we can continue with the with
the game i will definitely have a manual
later here
sharing his experience
yeah seven out of nine very impressive
score from the youngest grandmaster huge
huge score and he actually uh scored six
and a half out of seven in the last
seven right right i know it was very
very impressive yeah so after a four um
i have to take obviously because f3 is
hanging bishop h3 and d4 and
now i'm kind of you know untangling a
little bit
um pieces are coming off the board as
well um
and uh he has to addressed the bishop on
his three so he took
and uh king g2 yeah queen of five
and again pieces are coming off the
board right like i have this weakness on
c4 but i'm getting a lot of tempe i
actually have doubled fnc pawns right
now yeah that's funny um
and uh but i do get a lot of initiative
here i felt like and
here i thought maybe h6 was
an idea for black at least
try to prevent bishop g5
um
i'm not sure how good it is but
i was looking at that
for the most part
because what he did in the game felt
like i again just come in with tempo
like in the next five moves and he just
has no time to take on c4 so he had
bishop g5 rook f1 after king f7 now mata
4 is an idea 96 was an idea he has to
play this
uh and what if he takes on c4 now
yeah instead of rookie yeah probably not
f4 then
yeah knight to f4 very nice
yeah this looks like it's too much
activity
and i can always play 96 and then f4
again and
this was probably something that he
missed
from afar at least yeah possibly
possibly um
i love the uh question mark exclamation
mark move on d5 um
no but it helps it helps it definitely
helps yeah knight f4
and we liked her position a lot here
yeah i thought it was
yeah almost winning i went back on with
the engine on it uh because during
broadcast we actually expected exactly
what happened in the game and we thought
it was very bad for black the engine
found this magical move rook g8
good luck finding that over the board
yeah and thought that black was still
doing okay yeah i think rouge 8 is not
difficult to find but you have to make a
choice right you can't make all three
like rook g8 rookie 8 or 68 you can't
play all three right so you have to make
one out of those three and rook jade
makes some sense because you defend g7
obviously
um
so take on c5
yeah d7 or 97 yeah that's probably yeah
the engine wanted to go b5 b5 yeah
knight c6 comes you know and
yeah and somehow it was not so afraid
but after rookie 8 i would really like
to remove rookie four we were actually
analyzing rook d1 and stuff like that
but rookie four came on the board we saw
the whole line with b5 knight c7 and a4
and we thought yeah this is actually
very clean
and it seemed like he didn't recover
well
you are a grandmaster don't put yourself
down so much v5 knight c7 and it was
just smooth sailing from here yeah yeah
it was
a pretty clean game here and after um
yeah
titus always uh a big pleasure to see
you here at the saint louis chess club
tell us a little bit about your plans
going forward your chess plans going
forward you live in the united states
right now right yeah i live in the
states but i do travel quite a bit back
to europe sometimes and um
i in my interview before the tournament
i said this was probably going to be the
most important tournament of the year so
again just
maybe put a little bit too much pressure
on myself coming into it
um also got you know
the the five blacks so that was
unfortunate but
uh i do hope to play in the olympia if
that happens uh yeah it's very uncertain
right now obviously what's happening in
in the world
um and yeah i do plan to play a bit
chess here in the states as well there
is a tournament in dallas i think in
virginia
so yeah just
play some chess you know and see how it
goes hopefully better than than this
time well thank you very much for
joining us here in the studio titus and
good luck in your travels thank you
christian
thank you certainly